je voudrais m'excuser toutes les
personnes que j'ai pu blesser je m'en
suis pas rendu compte sur le coup je me
croyais à l'avenir
mettez le mettais l'ensemble de la vidéo
mais pas du tout elle est plus longue de
la vidéo bon c'est toujours elle
toujours à la ramasse oui moi je suis
libre à vos noms et
on lui disait excusez-vous à sa manière
il s'excuse vous voulez quoi vous voulez
qu'ils fassent quoi il y va il s'excuse
il garde le mot je ne comprends pas que
son compte soit suspendu c'est bien je
trouve qu'il a réfléchi et il le fait en
restant lui-même c'était pas facile donc
moi je lui dis bravo alors oui non mais
nous prend pour des cons là en fait va
nous prendre pour des cons il dérape une
première fois gravement il vient au
plateau ils essayent de nous
sensibiliser en nous racontant son
histoire en disant voilà ce n'est pas
facile pour moi et en fait là ils
montrent qu'ils se foutent de notre
gueule parce qu'il fait une vidéo en se
moquant de tout le monde et par bon mais
évidemment on ne peut jamais cautionné
les menaces et évidemment c'est ce qu'on
a lu qui reçoivent des menaces mais là
il fait tout pour ça arrive donc en fait
il en train de se moquer nous est son
seul but c'est qu'on parle de lui et
croyez moi qu'il était très content de
venir vendre l'île privée quelques
abonnés il mais je suis pas du tout
d'accord ils étudient sort moque de nous
tu te rends compte pour lui il est
vilipendé la démo nas il est tout seul
il y va et là vous ne l'enfoncé encore
elio moi je le défaut vraiment pas ce
que sont ses défauts mais si valérie et
oui mais c'est facile
à écouter alors ne changeait pas
d'arrêter ce que disait m mais vraiment
parce que ce que racontait mathieu m'a
profondément touché quand il disait en
parlant de son os de son cas qu'il était
croyant que et que lui même s'était
sentie rejetée par l'église et que donc
il entendait le l'appel de ce garçon
mais et le garçon dit oui c'était un
appel à dire je suis pas une brebis
égarée arrêtez de me voir et là tout
d'un coup on nous dit on nous dit
linverse là tout d'un coup il nous dit
en fait je reviens mais dans une église
pour m'excuser s'est alors retrouvé la
vie de daniel qui a été extrêmement
choqué par la première vidéo daniel
alors là je voudrais juste avoir une
pensée pour ses parents parce que ses
parents ce moment ils ont des vraiment
on a annoncé leur adresse il habite à
tous loin de paris ils ont des menaces
quotidiennes il l'a mis en scène la
maman qui pleure donc ça aujourd'hui
c'est quoi alors non non mais je veux
dire là commencé comme ça c'est encore
il dit nous a dit sur le plateau ça fait
deux ans qu'il fait des choses qui sont
quand même très polémique non mais c'est
vrai qu'on revienne sur cet extrait de
la tees encore là la procédure soit
choqué je parle de vous ah bah moi moi
oui il va évidemment mais des actes
c'est plus ou pas là ah non mais là je
fais là je peux pas j'ai déjà l'autre
jour c'était sûr mais ça scandaleux mais
la lie et voilà c'est la surenchère
c'est il nous a dit nous a dit de
l'autre jour moi je m'excuserai pas il
le fait comme ça c'est une surenchère ce
je ne peux pas supporter ça c'est je
pense moi en priorité là à ses parents
parce que c'est un petit con voilà
excusez moi je trouve même qu'on lui
donne beaucoup trop d'importance et une
tribune beaucoup plus important
moi pour moi c'est un enfant perdu ses
moyens si ces ambiances et les réseaux
sociaux c'est un enfant perdu des
réseaux sociaux donc après bon on l'a il
a mis un col roulé il a mis un pull je
veux dire il n'a pas tout marqué il a il
sait bien habillé pour faire sa vidéo
moi je lui en veux pas parce que pour
moi c'est un petit con et je me dis
qu'il faut pas non plus s'acharner sur
le gie il faut pas lui faire là de sa
vie un enfer je veux bien qu'il ya plein
de gens qui soit blessé je suis la cible
en plus donc je je je me sens aussi
concernés par ce qu'il a fait mais là
les gars il a mis un col roulé il a fait
a vite fait il a fait un relevé de
viande excuse moi me fait demi la
suivante c'est tout le monde et
les week-ends mais les salles ont laissé
leur ont déjà vu les messages vendredi
l'a vu la dernière fois que ça fait il a
reçu des messages et moi je vous ai
regardé vendredi et je vous entendez
tous ça c'est un enfant c'est un enfant
il a 18 ans et regardent et il a dit ça
on a en parlé comme ça
coiffé son enfant 18 ans à 18 ans
j'étais au tac je n'étais pas un enfant
il ya des gens à 18 ans ils ont déjà des
responsabilités
connaît à 18 ans je veux dire il a
quitté sa province
18 ans tu peux tu peux comprendre leur
respect le respect des institutions des
églises des mosquées des synagogues et
tu peux comprendre que tu vas blessés
des religieux à 12
[Musique]
810 est prévue vendredi vous avez
vendredi elle a tué son
frère et bien son frère à celui de black
pour une fois mais il pense qu'il
devrait être suivi
c'est important aussi le climat il
devrait être suivi parce que ce sont des
traumatismes qui le décrit ce sont des
appels au secours en effet quand je ne
sais pas si il voit un psychologue ou
psychiatre mais il faudrait qu'il en
parle à un professionnel parce qu'on va
comme une montée comme ça en crescendo
et ça on un jour vous pourrez vraiment
ils sont exagérées plus match il a des
gens et les gens qui ont mangé
alors s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît
gilbert daydé cela derrière cela
derrière vous je voudrais m'excuser
voulait
vraiment je ne comprends pas et moi
c'est quelqu'un qui est fragile ou
s'abandonner
je m'embrouille avec toi je vais bien
rasé ont heureusement je vais pisser sur
ta voiture noire mais ce que je
[Applaudissements]
vais quitter cette aventure qu'est ce
qu'une clause du loup ce qu'ils mangent
hormis une dose mais non on n'est pas
une dose la plus haute des changes il
quand même bien une excuse abîmées alors
dire c'est que ce mec-là c'est un modèle
malheureusement pour plein de jeunes
passent contre guy la percée il est
connu il faisait voilà pardon mais il ya
aucun mérite à faire ça demain si vous
filme en train de tabasser quelqu'un
dans la rue oui vous allez faire des
vues vous allez passer à la télé vous
avez passé sur les réseaux sociaux est
ce que c'est bien pour autant non je
pense qu'il ya d'autres moyens d'être
créatif et de se faire voir et de se
faire connaître que de faire n'importe
quoi il ya des limites quand même la
deuxième chance je vous connaissez pas
vous alors la
deuxième chance et regarde ce qu'il en
fait je suis désolé mais sous les yeux
de tema daniel non mais c'est vrai il
nous a expliqué en fait il est rentré
par hasard dans une église il a fait son
truc il voulait même pas les mettre sur
les réseaux sociaux il les met sur les
réseaux sociaux y voit que c'est que
c'est jugé comme ça là il en remet une
couche il ya vraiment lancer leur saison
oui on adore qu'on aime qui m'envoient
insulte à dieu dieu le père c'est vrai
que c'est un petit peu ce que vous
disiez peut-être voilà j'ai compris ce
qu'elle voulait dire raymondin c'est
vrai que raymonde voilà mon avion et
fort qu'elles reviennent nous voir
vraiment la folie ce qui ce qui arrive
j'espère mais je comprends pas c'est
simple ces refrains fois que je vois
défendre autant moyens cru que compliqué
parce que ce jeune homme a des
fragilités qui lamine les écraser
quelqu'un mais laissez moi finir
benjamin parce que c'est quelqu'un qui
est perturbé et moi les jeunes perturbé
il faut les aider j'ai envie de leur
tendre la main et je crains que là on le
fait c'est tout ça il y va pour le mieux
vous n'imaginez pas pour lui aller
là-bas s'exposait faire des excuses en
tenue correcte
j'ai jaugé mais vous n'étiez pas avec
moi j'avais défendu vendredi c'est
honnêtement je vais vous retournez votre
mascotte habitué des rires
je l'aimais répondu je l'avais défendu
parce que les messages de tolérance j'ai
compris le message effectivement il
avait sur le plateau un comportement qui
étaient là dedans par dont il avait déjà
fait une bêtise kita et je trouve que
après avoir fait les missions qu'il a
fait ici qui était très suivi où je
pense que les gens ont peut-être compris
la démarche à ce moment là pourquoi est
ce qu'il va faire ça
et là des skins d'ighil à elle du coup
ça annule tout le message de demander et
c'est dommage ben moi je trouve que
c'est aussi tout ce que ça génère
derrière c'est que ce jeune homme là il
a été harcelé il va être encore cyber
harceler guillaume l'a très bien dit ça
va encourager aussi d'autres jeunes eux
sa fille mais j'ai eu un discours très
très bien tous les deux je trouve
mais c'est vrai que ça risque
d'encourager des jeunes à vouloir se
mettre en lumière et à vouloir faire des
vues et ensuite certains gens c'est ça
vous choque ça vous parce que par les
boues oui dit sous le choc ça me choque
dans le sens où ce geste je n'estime pas
que sont des excuses voilà je ne suis
pas d'accord avec jésus à la fois
d'accord ici il y a une façon de faire
des excuses il ya une façon de se
comporter et on a une liberté de ne
s'exprimer mais il n'y a pas non plus il
faut quand même considérer qu'on peut
recéler religion qu'on peut heurter
certaines communautés regarder la tv ni
daniel également c'est vrai moi je sais
qu'il y en a plein qui ont été très
longues et daniel regagnait la joue par
l'enroulement vraiment très possible
c'est parcequ'elle il voulait dire je je
je je confirme que pour moi c'est un
petit con mais j'en ai plus contre le
monde des réseaux sociaux et le monde
actuel dans lequel on dit plutôt que
contre ce petit lac i qui tu veux
absolument faire du buzz qui veut faire
bévue en faisant des conneries voilà
wells après juste moi voilà c'est ça qui
génère ce qu'on a des sondages
aujourd'hui je pense qu'on en a mais
voilà merci gilles t'ai parlé même temps
j'ai terriblement tomber 10 93%
tomber dans le panneau il n'y a aucun
message derrière sa gym tu vas pas que
c'est tombé dans le panneau de
l'histoire de sa vie l'a fait mais c'est
elle rappelle que ça marche ça fait
trois mois qu'elle en train de préparer
son mariage
à dakar avec
[Applaudissements]